Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
two dangerously delusional members of
Congress got into a verbal fight in the
women's bathroom when dim-witted dunce
clashes with brainless buffoon this is
what you get
it is being reported by The Daily Beast
and summarized by lgbtq Nation Marjorie
Taylor green and Lauren bobert allegedly
got into a screaming match in the
women's restroom
um both green and bobert have said trans
women are a threat to CIS women in
public restrooms and locker rooms but it
appears the real aggression in the
women's room writes this article is
coming from them the two far-right
anti-lgbtq plus extremists reportedly
got into a shouting fight January 3rd
just as Congress was getting ready to
vote for speaker of the house according
to several unnamed sources who spoke to
the Daily Beast
during the 15 votes that lasted for an
entire week you might remember that
bobert and some others were trying to
prevent Kevin McCarthy from being
speaker green is a member of that same
Wing sometimes known as the freedom
caucus but she ended up siding with
McCarthy as we now know
the article goes on to say according to
One Source green was exiting a stall
when she confront confronted beauber
about the latter's plan to thwart
McCarthy's election green allegedly
accused bobert of taking money from
McCarthy for her campaign but not
showing loyalty now she allegedly asked
you were okay taking millions of dollars
from McCarthy but you refused to vote
for him for speaker Lauren green
questioned Beau Bear's loyalty to
McCarthy and afterwards were exchanged
bobert stormed out that's when Lauren
said don't be ugly before bobert quote
ran out like a little school girl when
questioned about the altercation bobert
said see you later bye
green hasn't commented either
uh congresswoman Debbie Dingle din jail
Dingle was reportedly in the restroom
when this happened but she's not talking
about it what happens in the Ladies Room
stays in the ladies room this is um this
is part of this splintering of the
Republican party I know I've said it
before I you know apologies for those
who have heard this but you originally
had Republicans Pro and anti-trump
people like you know Mitt Romney in the
anti-trump camp you now still have the
anti-trump Republicans but you have Maga
or buffoonery call it whatever you want
call it peaches for all I care to quote
Trump
um you now have Maga subdividing and
splintering and of course the dream
scenario would be that they Splinter
themselves into Oblivion whether it's
going to happen or not we just don't yet
know but um Lauren bobert and Marjorie
Taylor green ending up on opposite sides
of anything is certainly a sign that
that splintering is taking place the
important thing for the left is you know
I have never pushed for this false Unity
of the left there's room for diverse
views on the left and there are also
things that just aren't actually left
and so we shouldn't pretend that they
are
it's not about false Unity but right now
the left actually is quite United these
voices that I've always said are
relatively small in terms of power
they're very loud but they're relatively
small
um that do the Purity tests and the
litmus tests they are not getting nearly
the attention that they once did and
overall the left is pretty damn United
right now I think that it's critical at
a time when the right is splintering and
sub splintering and sub splintering add
infinitum hopefully
um that the left uh maintain focused on
the big issues that we are trying to
deal with that includes getting people
Health Care dealing with inequality
um help climate there's so many I don't
even know in what order to go the
education crisis the foreign policy
embarrassments that plagued us under
Trump on and on and on the left has an
opportunity to in contrast to what's
happening on the right look quite
organized and sane and United and allow
the right to continue destroying itself
meanwhile Republicans continue to just
do self-inflicted damage and I want to
talk about the the new anti-museum
anti-book positions that are surfacing
on the right
as many people know I'm a white ale type
of guy when it comes to beer and even
for those of us who drink responsibly
like me sometimes you still feel it the
next day and it can slow you down
especially when you start to get up
there in the years like me check out our
sponsor zebiotics which is a probiotic
drink that breaks down the byproduct of
alcohol responsible for those rough
mornings after drinking all you do is
drink a tiny bottle of zebiotics before
you have alcohol next day you'll feel
refreshed and ready to go the way it
works is when you drink a toxic
byproduct builds up in your gut and
that's what causes you to feel bad the
next day zibiotics produces an enzyme to
break down that byproduct and zebiotic
stands by their product 100 if it
doesn't work for you you get all your
money back no questions asked remember
we're talking about drinking responsibly
here I can't more highly prioritize
getting a good night's sleep zibiotics
is for responsible drinkers who just
want to get the most out of the next day
go to zebiotics.com Pacman get 15 off
your first order with the code Pacman
the link is down below